[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
terry bradshaw set to join us
on the program and terry let me start
with the obvious
how realistic was the fight scene in the
movie hooper with burt reynolds when you
uh got punched
the the tooth was a piece of paper
you know i had a i did have a gap there
i wore a flipper thing because
i took it out when i played and i
eventually had fixed but that was a
piece of paper
when i hit him on the helmet um i really
did
i hit him the first time and the helmet
didn't crack
it's pretty cracked cracked and glued
back
and so i hit him the first time and it
didn't crack
and so bert says you got to really hit
me
i said bert i mean i'll have to hit you
pretty hard he said
just really hit me so the second time i
really popped him
i mean i popped him good and then the
fight was
pretty much that i dove out a window
shattered my right elbow
landed on the concrete i mean landed on
asphalt
uh that that that fight scene was crazy
it was i mean it was
people were bleeding yeah it was good
well wait a minute
how did the steelers react to this
uh they didn't know about it
come on busting up the versa sack and
the bones in my elbow
they found out about it when blood
started draining back down in it
and um then i told you i told them what
happened but i was fine
i mean you know you could have a big old
blood bubble and the bone chips are in
there
sure sure yeah you know you've
experienced that
all in a day's work if i would if i
would have said
uh you could have said to bert you want
to change careers like you would have
been
bert dunber's career and he would have
changed and
you would have been a movie star do you
think both would have done it
well we always want to be something
we're not
so i think yeah he played football at
florida state he would have loved to
been an nfl player so i think switching
is always
very easy i think if you ask a player
i'm a singer or i try to sing so i would
always switch places with a
professional singer i'd love to have
sung like pavarotti
i mean i was switching heartbeat he'd be
a offensive lineman though he
big man so yeah i think so i think burp
definitely would have switched
if i would if i said you could have
switched with george strait
yes i was switched yes who's the
who's uh the person you sang with where
you went i'm
way over my skis here i did
uh well i never thought that
okay hey listen i've sung with the
isaac's
the great gospel group the isaacs and
boy they can they sing
and i've done several shows with them
and i
i hold my own i hold my hom my own
all right i've sing on the grand ole
opry uh four or five times
i'm i can sing i i'm not ashamed to step
up in front of anybody but i did a song
with glenn campbell
and uh i was nervous well number one it
was glenn campbell
but i was so nervous and it turned out
really good glenn made me sing good made
me comfortable
but i was extremely in intimidated by
glenn campbell
give me a little wichita lineman you got
a you got a little for me
no i'm not gonna do that you can't make
what
you just told me how good a singer you
are i don't have a piano here i i
gotta have a piano to sing really all
right honey
i need a piano next time i bring a piano
yeah hey listen i sing all the time when
people ask me on
what is that thing i do facebook or
facebook they say
sing a song i sing but dan patrick you
asked me to sing and bear and dogs
i'm afraid i would be i would do poorly
and that would upset me i would sing a
little johnny cash if that meant you
would sing a little
glenn camel okay let me have it i
fell into a burning ring of fire
went down down down flames
they went higher and they heard burns
burns the radio fire
the ring of fire
what do you think the taste of love is
sweet
when hearts like ours meet
i felt for you like a child
oh but the fire went wild there you go
i know i think it's good i think it's
good that's not how i sing but
uh finish this sentence i always feel a
lot smarter when i'm next to whom
you
and i was gonna say you i
i uh i think i feel a lot
i don't think like that number one ever
but when i'm around people that think
that ain't no football reporters or
you know guys like you uh that know the
game but you
really don't know how the game is
structured and why you do this or that
uh not that i would ever laugh or
nothing's ever said that makes me laugh
at a
at being being interviewed by someone
like dan patrick
but you know that they're doing their
best
and they know they know enough to have a
conversation
but they don't really they don't really
know
football but nor should they i mean you
just can't
you can't possibly know it but i never
think
i'm smarter than that guy because
normally
that's not the case but when did you
embrace this persona
because that you didn't come into the
nfl
like this i don't think did you that you
know i talked to tony dungy and he said
you know terry is good at playing dumb
he's not um but but you had to embrace
this personality at some point
i did you fight it um
you fight it and you find out early in
your career
that that's a that's a that's a battle
you're not going to win arguing with
writers or pouting and not doing
interviews and so
i learned really early uh the best way
for me to
get along with you dan when you
criticize me
is to and like you even more
because you're doing your job and having
an opinion and i'm not saying you've
done that i'm just using an example
but um when i when i started to embrace
it
i found that it defused the situation
and i i'm a funny guy i like to have fun
except when i played i wasn't giggling
and laughing or cutting jokes in the
huddle but
i just found out that life's a lot of a
lot
easier if people finally realize they
can't hurt you
and then you say i'm dumb yeah yeah hey
let's go with it i don't have a problem
you know got a pe degree barely
graduated but i graduated
you know it's all good i act crazy so
i act a little nuts and i like
i like that i like i am i am who
i am what i am and so i will never
apologize
for that do you want me to act like uh
tom brady
i would be bored tears if i acted like
that you want me to be like
joe montana these are people i love and
respect
and not love but i respect no i i'm not
going to do that take many i'm not going
to do that that
is not me i you have to be true to
yourself
and people will like you fart or they
won't and
i found that humor and accepting the
dumb image
was the best way it was the safe way it
was the easy way for me
where are the rings the rings are a
louisiana tech
in a in a plastic case
trophy case right so players that come
through tech
will see my jersey and and the rings
and the hall of fame jacket and they'll
realize that they can come to louisiana
tech and that too could happen to you
so i donated them to the university you
can start
a team with any quarterback aside from
yourself
all time roger staubach
love roger starback he's underrated
terry
oh he's so s he's just amazing
amazing we talk about brady you know and
all
he's accomplished and i have nothing but
great things to say
but for me for my money i'm going with
stallback
uh you're doing uh frito lay with a
bunch of uh
star star cheese yeah you got some big
big names
in there it's it's the cover they're
doing this one commercial is going to
come on right before the coin toss
and as betis and i are re
acting the immaculate reception and i
crash into the
the chips and everything on the table
and we have joe montana and jerry rice
troy aikman pops in on it um
it's pretty it's pretty crazy but it's
fun
free ola is a great company i've been
doing stuff for them for a number of
years
and i also would add to that they're
owned by pepsico so have a pepsi while
you're doing it how's that
but it's not the immaculate reception
though terry
oh it isn't what is it well i thought
the pass had something to do with it as
well
oh in the commercial you're talking
about oh no i'm arguing
i was giving you real life credit right
i'm well in
yeah someone had to throw that thing i
mean you got to
you gotta you gotta avoid getting sacked
you gotta gun it down there about 30
yards
you gotta make sure the other guy hits
it with his chest
did it touch frenchy when it left
tatum's chest
and did franco trap it or did he catch
it and then we gotta have an argument
and we gotta have
chaos break out and uh yeah
gotta have all that they all started
with me i am the hey i'm the man
you are you are uh thanks for spending
time
and next time i beat a piano i bring a
piano next time oh hey
uh hey you bring the piano in and i'm
your man thank you terry
good to talk to you buddy bye dan uh
terry bradshaw